hi my name is Rajiv single Aris I'm the
president of alcatel-lucent in Asia
Pacific and I'm also the chairman of the
ICT Global Agenda Council over the
course of today I had an opportunity to
sit in a number of sessions and listen
to perspectives on for instance how East
Asia can transform the global economy
and how we make East Asia more resilient
to potential future crises the
perspectives I heard from a vantage
point of someone in the communications
industry were actually quite interesting
there was a common or shared belief that
ICT was going to be an essential part of
future competitiveness and so
policymakers acknowledged that as they
diversify the economies of this part of
the world they need to move to more
knowledge based economies and by doing
that make them more resilient to
external shocks like the recession in
Europe like a currency crisis or like
the problems that emerge in 97 and 98 in
doing so the ASEAN countries that block
of 600 million that is in many ways
quite diverse if you think about me amar
with a 1-percent mobile phone
penetration to countries like Singapore
and Malaysia with well over a hundred
percent mobile penetration that will
help create more uniform economies and
better standard of living across those
economies thanks